[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
francia 24 rosa perez más de una lista
en el estudio rosa vamos a abrir esta
revista de prensa con algunas portadas
estadounidenses que destacan las
novedades de la matanza de 10 personas
en buffalo en el estado de nueva york en
eeuu un crimen calificado de racista por
todas las autoridades incluso por el
presidente demandó a contextualizar un
poco entonces rosa que ocurrió y luego
vamos con las portadas buenos días raúl
exactamente como decías fue una masacre
en la que diez personas fueron
asesinadas en la ciudad de buffalo en el
estado de nueva york eeuu y
particularmente en un barrio obrero y de
mayoría afroestadounidense y esto es
importante de destacar porque el
presunto autor de la masacre payton
gendron ha sido identificada como
identificado perdón como un supremacista
blanco y es que de las 13 personas a las
que disparó 11 eran negras y dos blancas
de hecho decimos presunto autor porque
él todavía no ha confesado y no ha sido
condenado pero de llegó hasta
retransmitir en vivo la masacre a través
de la plataforma digital tweets y según
un comisario de la policía de buffalo
las pruebas que hemos recogido hasta
ahora indican que se trata de un crimen
completamente racista y de odio esto fue
lo que este agente declaró a la prensa
así es rosa entonces vamos ahora con el
'new york times' en la portada escrita
por nicholas confesor y karen iuris
efectivamente y en la portada que ahora
veremos aquí detrás nuestro se ve la
imagen de una superviviente de la
masacre haciendo consell a consolada en
una ceremonia no memorial que tuvo lugar
ayer en buffalo y entre las líneas del
'new york times' se destacan a las
palabras del obispo darius prisión de
búfalo que se refirió a los sacerdotes
de eeuu y de más allá y les dijo que si
predicaban la palabra del señor y no
reconocen que hay personas que todavía
odian a los negros pueden irse al
infierno con el asesino si están en
silencio en este momento son no son mis
amigos dijo en una relación a que el
silencio es pues muchas veces cómplice
también y el 'new york times' e
identifica a algunas de las víctimas que
murieron en esta masacre raúl y es
impactante ver la cotidianidad no de las
escenas en las que murieron bueno en las
que fueron asesinadas digamos dije 'new
york times' los muertos incluyen arons
leather juniors de 55 años policía
retirado que trabajaba como guardia de
seguridad quien se enfrentó al autor de
la masacre bruce with él una mujer de 86
años abuela de 8 otros murieron
intentando escapar
célestin chan y 65 años quien sólo
quería comprar fresas para un pastel de
frutas o robert a trulli 32 años que
estaba comprando comida para la cena
heyward paterson 67 que murió ayudando a
colocar la compra en el auto de otro
vecino no entiendo cómo estas cosas
siguen ocurriendo simplemente por no
tener tolerancia por no respetar y por
no respetar la vida de las demás
personas rosa la verdad que es bien
indignante que escribe el periodista a
kevin johnson el usa today pues en
relación a lo que decías no se dice acto
malvado y enfermizo calificado de crimen
de odio porque precisamente es
importante considerar que este no es un
acto aislado sino que se enmarca dentro
de una peligrosa ideología como es el
supremacismo blanco y dice en un
subtítulo ataque en búfalo refleja la
amenaza interna más letal y es que de
hecho los extremistas motivados por el
odio racial y étnico son considerados la
amenaza más peligrosa a nivel de
terrorismo interno por las autoridades
de eeuu y de hecho en 2019 el fbi
consideró el terrorismo supremacista
blanco una amenaza de máximo nivel
después de una ola de ataques racistas
en estados unidos y también usa today
destaca las declaraciones a la prensa
del comisario de policía de buffalo
joseph gra maglia dice un acto de algo
de alguien que tiene odio en su corazón
en su alma y en su cabeza rosa que
resaltan jimmy build nicole free man y
ginger ams en el bolsillo no pues vemos
que la imagen es la misma que la que
veíamos en él new york times' y dice
básicamente que el sospechoso de la
matanza de odio fue evaluado en 2021 por
amenazas y es que es importante destacar
que tiene 18 años el presunto autor de
la matanza por lo que el año pasado
estaba en el instituto y de hecho en un
trabajo en el que se pedía a los alumnos
cuáles eran sus planes para después de
graduarse él dijo que planeaba ejecutar
un tiroteo un ataque suicida masivo en a
raíz de este comentario la policía lo
llevó a un instituto psiquiátrico donde
fue evaluado durante un día y medio y
después pues le dejaron ir sin hacerle
más seguimiento y precisamente en las
columnas del wall street journal también
leemos lo siguiente que escriben los
periodistas parece haber sido motivado
el autor por conspiraciones racistas que
descubrió en internet durante la
pandemia de acuerdo con un documento
subido a internet a la policía la
policía cree que le escribió el autor se
describe a sí mismo como fascista
supremacista blanco racista y antisemita
el documento plantea detalles para un
ataque parecido a lo ocurrido el sábado
incluido el objetivo de matar a tantas
personas negras como fuera posible y es
que de hecho él era seguidor de esta
teoría racista llamada el gran reemplazo
o la gran sustitución que new york
times' se describe como una creencia
tóxica en que la raza blanca está en
riesgo una teoría que conduce a la
violencia y que convierte odio en terror
y que tienen bastantes adeptos en
francia no para ligarlo con lo que vamos
ahora así es rosa super rápido por favor
que ya no nos quedan tiempo pues
precisamente ha sido criticada la
portada del 'plan de este semanario
francés de derechas en la que se ve
digamos al líder de la francia insumisa
jean luc mélenchon quien ha liderado la
unión de izquierdas de cara a las
legislativas en que pone el otro le pen
no hoy es que bueno como siempre es poco
riguroso y de poca honestidad
intelectual comparar a la extrema
derecha con la izquierda no lo de
siempre no se puede poner al mismo nivel
al racismo con el anti racismo ryan bien
rosa y poner en alerta pues las
autoridades porque siempre en estos
casos de odio y también sobre todo
cuando se comete un acto terrorista las
personas siempre han estado bajo el ojo
de la policía y al final siempre
terminan cometiendo los crímenes
entonces por un llamado a las
autoridades a que revisen realmente sus
procedimientos y no dejar a estas
personas así como así libres
gracias.rosa por toda la información en
esta revista de prensa nos vemos mañana
con más vamos directo hasta